بخموت الفقده لاي قيمه استراتيجيه استماتت
كيبو موسكو للسيطره عليها لتنتهي العشره
الاشهر الاخيره بانتصار الجانب الروسي اذا
لكن دعونا نتحدث عن هذه المدينه الصغيره
الواقعه شرقي اوكرانيا كانت اثقلت كاهل
روسيا وتحولت ايضا عبئا وانتصار معنوي
ومكاسب دون مغزى فالمعارك الطويله
والمكلفه تركت جنودها اذا مرهقين ومحاصرين
مع فرصه ضئيله للتقدم كما تقول وولز ورغم
ان الدفاع عن ضخمه لفتره طويله كان كلف
اوكرانيا بشكل كبير لكن كيف لم تنتشر ايضا
في هذه المدينه ولم تنشر ايا من الاولياء
هذه الالويه التي نتحدث عنها التي كان
جربها ايضا الدنو الجنود وايضا جهزها
الحلفاء الغربيون استعدادا لاي هجوم في
هذه المنطقه اذا ما تحدثنا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات